first of all thank you guys for making
the time
uh uh to be on uh with us i know the
audience has been anticipating this for
a while
uh obviously uh when we had that sit
down together we were together for
three days i think nearly 30 hours of
footage which has now come to a
completion of 10 episodes
of which there's behind the scenes
there's a lot of different things that
the audience will be seeing but you know
i kind of want to ask you guys a couple
open-ended questions how are you doing
right now with
in regards to this project being
launched how are you guys doing to
yourself maybe michael if you can uh
tell us uh on your end of your level of
enthusiasm with this mafia states of
america project
i'm doing great patrick i just want to
get it underway a lot of people are
asking about it uh you know a lot of
different comments and uh it's time we
get it out there you know i'm very
enthused to see it happen
sammy how about yourself
i guess yes uh i'm
waiting for it to come out i've been
waiting a while
it's a little awkward time right now but
i'm waiting for it to come out as well
well i remember when we had you on the
podcast you made it very clear when i
said it may come out this year it may
come out next year you had a very
strategic way of making sure it came out
this year which is
uh uh coming out in 2021 instead of next
year
and we're pretty excited about launching
it but uh
michael uh uh sammy uh for yourself
the market you know it seems so many
people are anticipating this
conversation between the two of you uh
specifically since we had so many
different discussions from the life on
your end uh what where are you at right
now yourselves
uh knowing at this phase of the season
when this is being launched meeting has
there been
any conversations between the two of you
about this project yourself so sammy
what are you thinking right now what's
on your mind
well we did have conversations about it
and i thought we were on the same page
as far as trying to uh put this back
together
and solving our problems
i'm not sure if this did solve our
problems
uh michael put out a video just not too
low and i didn't like this [ __ ] video
and i think we had some words
so uh but we still did this i don't want
to interfere with the project i didn't
want to destroy it or hurt it in any way
and uh
but um
i'm looking forward to it i watched uh
not all of the episodes but some of them
looks like they're pretty well done
and um there's some issues i have with
some of the things and some of the
conversations that me and michael have i
think we'll straighten it out
after this or before it i i don't really
care when but uh
so that's my opinion of it right now
got it so
you know
michael sammy uh maybe uh it's good for
the audience to hear from your and when
you first flew in and we came to the
property and we had that one meeting
together in the room it was myself the
two of you uh i want to say
kurt was there i think richie was a few
people were involved in that meeting
that we had in that room uh next door
what was your expectation going in and
then at the same time what was your uh
uh you know outcome at the end when you
left was it what you expected it to be
when you left what was your thoughts
when you went in and when you left
michael yourself
yeah i didn't know what to expect look
sammy and i have uh you know two
different uh
perceptions of this life both before and
after
and i knew that that was going to be
some controversy between us and
obviously it was patrick you were there
you know i think uh we got heated at
times
because we do strongly disagree
um but you know all in all
look we're two maid guys and at the end
of the day i think we knew how to
conduct it ourselves even though things
got heated at times you know
it's kind of like a blast back to the
past and you kind of remember the way
things are supposed to go and i think in
the end they went that way you know how
we feel about each other right now i
don't know look sammy said something he
said i didn't like
and maybe i said some things that he
didn't like and as a result there's
still some tension between us but that's
just the way it goes you know it's uh
you know how it how it ultimately ends
up is really you know depends on the two
of us and we'll see what happens
yeah well michael
it's not that you know the way it ended
i thought it ended good i think it went
well
between us
and uh just recently you put out an
inter uh a video
that i'm completely disturbed with we
had language back and forth with each
other i think we know let's not [ __ ]
so right now i feel betrayed by you by
what you put out
what we did on this
program
was a beautiful thing you're right it
was goes in austria in full bloom again
it made me feel good about sitting with
you it maybe changed my opinion of you
and i think it went very well
that we did have some heated
times
but end result it went like goes in
austria it's supposed to go
but what you did after that that video
really disturbed the [ __ ] out of me up
until right now i didn't even want to
sit down on this video to tell you the
truth
but i'm in this deep i went in this far
and i'm not the type of guy who's going
to walk away and leave everybody
dangling
so
that's that's the way i feel from that
video but the the the
mafia states of america that situation
and what patrick did and what you did
yes we do have tremendous differences of
opinion
uh along as it goes on
as far as destroying families and all of
that stuff
you know it did to some people but not
to other people
and when we talk about people who
cooperated which you did as well
with navi walters you want to really get
into that right now
but
you know to sit there and say you know
this is horrible what these people did
and they caught a break
and uh
all of this stuff
belittling them and putting them
down for another program that's going to
come out with john gotti jr
blew me away
and then the second thing you
you prayed for me
that's another thing that bloom really
blew me away because i'm not a fool
i'm a street thug i'm just as smart as
you
maybe you underestimate my education
compared to your education but i know
when i'm being [ __ ]
okie doked or try to make me soft uh get
take it easy because of the video it's
not supposed to bother me no more
but it does and it made it that was like
icing on the cake to me
so it made me real angry so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you